Connor welcome to camp et thank you you
have all the amenities really I mean we
have everything coloring books juicebox
ring pop but no campsite would be
complete without some s'mores yeah so
I'm gonna make them for you tada nope
all right no that's an outlet very good
it's real it's not props more ok cool oh
ha you went for it did you ever go like
to a summer camp though like you know
like them I've only been to a couple
summer camps but did you I'm hosting my
own summer camp I knew it that was my
next question I mean wow I guess you're
running the show here my summer camp is
a creator camp and it's focused around
like YouTube creator so we're gonna be
doing uh the traditional camp things
like archery and like swimming and alike
but we're also gonna be doing things
with camera is a photography and YouTube
that's gonna be yeah it's really modern
really fun it's a camper you're allowed
to use your phone yes right at certain
times at certain times like oh cuz you
gotta appreciate nature and life
sometimes yeah I know you're right
you're right you're right like VidCon is
kind of like summer camp it is right and
people literally like camp out they'd oh
yeah they I mean they really do camp out
actually but also you get to hang out
with some fellow creators though yes how
much fun is that it's the best that's
like my favorite part about VidCon
obviously seeing viewers is amazing too
but like I get to see all my friends in
one place which never happens how many
VidCon this is for you this is like my
fourth or fifth really I've been a lot
you're like at that that so what I don't
know it goes down yet you can't tell
from the young fresh face but he's been
here he's has to come here J 87 years
I've been at VidCon what are your tips
to surviving this weekend tips it oh you
need a charger at all times water for
hydration purposes or do you need
happiness and excitement and that should
get you through it that's that's all you
need what else do you need nothing what
are you up to the rest of this year what
else can we look forward to eating us
some more the rest of the year besides
the camp and s'mores so I just launched
a new line of clothing here oh um for
common culture which is my lifestyle
brand working on regular YouTube content
I have a record label so working on
compilations tyler oakley's compilation
just came out under my record label
today lots of like I my secrets I'm a
singer oh she sings cool
i ah my lord kumbaya sorry had a lighter
sign me know when to your label Connor
well thanks for hanging out can't be
teased next year we'll have like archery
there you go okay okay that stays here